the reason i think passive income is
good is because theoretically if you
could make an extra 500 pounds a month
thousand pounds a month from a thing
that you didn't have to spend your own
time doing that means you can tick that
box of economic engine and then you can
spend your time doing the stuff you
actually want to do maybe that'll
involve quitting your actual job and
doing something different maybe involve
going part-time maybe involved spending
more time with your family and kids and
stuff having that financial freedom is
life-changing and passive income is one
path on that route to financial freedom
which is ultimately on that route to
living a happy healthy fulfilled life
ali abdul welcome to the show thanks for
having me on look at this lovely studio
that we're in i know it's still a work
in progress
beautiful so we've just got loads of
forest like plants on the background
yeah we are in some foliage i haven't
figured out a name for them yet but i
feel like you're gonna have some names
yeah that's very you yeah very you uh so
i've just recorded on your show yeah i'm
gonna return the favor fantastic and
talk about stuff on mine and what are we
talking about i want to talk about
passive income oh
okay sure another one of your specialist
subjects
i think
um yeah i've done a lot of reading
around it and dabbled with it
so let's see where the conversation goes
one of the interesting things is that
for most people
income is
we're not really taught about passive
income and multiple income streams the
the absolute peak that most people will
get is earn more than you spend
and try and get a put money into a
pension or some sort of isa of some kind
there's not really a very good
understanding of how you spread
your risk about how you can have
multiple income streams maybe people who
are not self-employed don't think that
this is the sort of thing they should be
doing for people who are self-employed
they might not have the time or the
understanding to actually be able to
work out what they should do so if
you're talking to someone about passive
income what's it why should someone even
be bothered why should someone even
think about it as an option yeah um
so the way uh the reason i think of it
as being being a good thing is
i think ultimately we're all trying to
live a life that's like happy and
meaningful and fulfilled and stuff like
that's
that's ultimately where we're all aiming
at with even even with all the stuff
with all the stuff you talk about in the
show that's that's our our destination
now the reason
a bit a big part of why
we might not get to that destination you
know there are there are various hurdles
that can get in the way for example if
you have a major health problem and
or
like yeah yeah for example if you have
like a major health problem that kind of
gets in the way of you living your best
life and so you want to try and solve
that health problem and if you for
example people who have chronic back
pain say that it just adds a real downer
to their quality of life forever like
there's not much you can do about that
and i think when it comes to money uh we
all need money to survive
um and the way that most of us make that
money that we need to survive is by
doing a thing a job that we go to for 40
hours plus a week that we spend 80 000
hours of our lives doing
now if you could magically make everyone
not need that money to survive
then i think
we would be more
more free to live our best life and and
and though i think of it it's almost
like in in board games i don't know have
you have you ever played those like
really long three hour long type board
games no but i know that you absolutely
love these freaking love that stuff tell
me about that um and and so there's a
game called agriculture which is like
it's it's like farmville but like board
game format i used to play with my
friends at uni
um and in a lot of these kind of
strategy board games you need to create
for yourself an economic engine of some
sort whether that is like i don't know
breeding sheep or getting collecting hay
or collecting wood or being the person
who lays brick within the context of the
board game and once you've built your
economic engine at that point you can
start winning like moving towards
victory points and winning the game i
think in real life we all need an
economic engine of some sort and it
would be really nice in a dream world if
the thing that we did to make money is
also the thing that makes it brings us
passion and joy and
genuinely contributes to us living our
best life but for most people including
for me that thing is not the same as the
thing that makes me money uh and so long
answer the question like the reason i
think passive income is good is because
theoretically if you could make an extra
500 pounds a month thousand pounds a
month 1500 a month from a thing that you
didn't have to spend your own time doing
that means you can tick that box of
economic engine and then you can spend
your time doing the stuff you actually
want to do maybe that'll involve
quitting your actual job and doing
something different maybe involve going
part-time maybe involve spending more
time with your family and kids and stuff
um
but
but having having that financial freedom
is life-changing and passive income is
one path on that route to financial
freedom which is ultimately on that
route to living a happy healthy
fulfilled life
how do you think about wealth like let's
say that you're talking to someone you
want to explain to them about wealth
creation and what what it is
how do you think about that do you think
about it in terms of you have a central
job and then you try and peel cash off
the top what's this sort of basis
um i guess it's
for me it's like how much money do i
need to live
and then how much money do i need to
have a good life
um
i.e good life to find us doing the
things that i want i want to do for me
personally i don't think my lifestyle is
particularly extravagant um and
therefore you know figure out what that
amount of money is usually the amount of
money i need to live is different to the
amount of money i would like to have in
order to live
to live a good life
and then i just think we need to figure
out a way of hitting those numbers
and for most people that's their job but
the multiple income streams is another
way of hitting those numbers and for
most people what i usually advise is
don't quit your job like do your job and
then in the evenings and weekends find
ways to build these side hustles and
projects that can make you money so that
in the future if you want you can quit
your job if that's what you want or you
can go part-time or you can continue
doing it if you really enjoy it but
either way it just gives you more
freedom and gives you more optionality
and certainly like we found that in the
pandemic people lost their jobs and
where you know this black swan event
happens that people can't imagine
happening since like 1919 or whatever uh
people lose their jobs and you realize
oh my god reliance on a single source of
income is not a very anti-fragile way of
living life as they say um and so
multiple streams of passive income
whether it's through investments or
through businesses or whatever is a way
of de-risking yourself so that's sort of
how i think about wealth like less so in
the sort of constructive wealth more in
the case of how much money do i need to
live how much money do i need to live a
good life does anyone need to sort
anything before they start thinking
about passive income is there any is
there a step 0.5 before we start with
step one
um
probably not i mean i think
the the issue with passive income is
actually yeah most people need to start
off with active income before they can
switch to passive income so you need to
have some money coming in through
something that you're doing it is very
hard to just
conjure up a stream of passive income
passive defined as you're not you're not
really working for it i guess we can go
into in into definitions but i think
active income
single stream start with a single stream
of income and then worry about like
diversifying that into multiple streams
cool stocks and shares
where do you start i don't know about
stocks and shares i don't know what to
put my money in yeah i don't know what
trading is
where do i start okay uh that leads us
into a long conversation basis so
practical advice
don't worry about it put money into if
you're in the uk into stocks and shares
isa which is a savings account or in
america you're roth ira or 401k and if
you can invest money invest it into a
stock market index fund uh basically
what that means is that you are instead
of buying one company like apple or
microsoft or tesla or google you're
buying a stake in the top 500 companies
in the in america which would just so
happen like if you put 100 quid in
something called the s p 500 um
three pounds would go to apple and you'd
own three pounds of apple two pounds
you'd own two pounds of alphabet a and b
so google you'd own two pounds of
microsoft two pounds of amazon and so on
and that means you can invest in the
stock market without worrying about
trying to cherry pick individual stocks
which doesn't work for anyone unless
you're like a very very very
professional hedge fund manager and even
then for those guys picking stocks
doesn't really work so that would be my
advice to people um but i think it does
help to have a first principles
understanding of what the stock market
isn't and how that kind of stuff works i
saw a video of warren buffett's and
charlie munger giving an end-of-year
address a couple of years ago and they
were talking about i think warren had
made a bet
with a bunch of hedge fund managers to
see if they could beat the s p 500 have
you seen this video yep
so sick
so well can you explain
what happened and why that seems to be
the case
yeah so the the thing with
with funds
basically if you're a rich person you
want to you want to you want your money
to grow you don't want if your money
sits in a bank account onto your
mattress it deflates over time because
of inflation uh because the government
prints more money which gets us into
conversation about crypto and stuff
which will we won't go down because i'm
not very familiar with that space trying
to understand it myself and basically
money sitting on its own reduces its
value over time and therefore if you
have money you want it to ideally
increase its value over time and one way
you can do that you can do it in real
estate or you can do it by buying and
investing in stocks and shares so you
own a percentage of a company
if you do what what i recommend and what
warren buffett and charlie munger
recommends i recommend you just invest
in an index fund which tracks the whole
stock market and you don't have to worry
about it but some people invest in
actively managed funds so that's
basically i would give you some money
i'd say chris here is a million pounds i
want you to grow my million pounds
you would say oh [ __ ] at least give me a
million pounds i need to grow it but i
need to do something other than just
invest in the fund in the index fund
right because i need to i need to try
and be beat the market that's what
beating the market means and so you
think you know what i think tesla's
going to do well i think netflix is
going to well i think i think pets.com
is going to do well and i think i don't
know febreze is going to do well i'm
going to put a quarter of a million of
all this money into those things and i'm
really going to hope that it outperforms
what what it would have done had i put
it into just the top 500 companies in
the us without thinking about it
and it apparently according to warren
buffett i haven't read the research on
this first hand myself but what warren
buffett says and what a lot of advice on
this industry is that
the funds that do well one year like
let's say chris's fund returns 20 so my
million goes to 1.2 million whereas the
s p 500 the index market only returned
10
so if i was average joe investing in the
index fund i'd make 10 but if i gave my
money to you chris i'd make 20
uh but there's no guarantee that the
next year your fund is also making 20
and there's also no guarantee that in
year three your fund is still doing well
and it turns out that there are very few
funds if any that can actually just beat
the market overall which is what this
bet was that warren buffett did with all
these hedge fund managers and he ended
up winning it um and giving the money to
literally doing something that anybody
could do pressing go all in on the s p
500 which is in itself kind of a hedged
type of investment because it's across
so many different companies and you're
talking about professional hedge fund
managers that were spending time and
charging commissions and doing research
and looking at is this overpriced what's
the r number on the the fibonacci
sequence over over trend all this stuff
exactly just put it in the s p 500 and
the s p b all of them that's the one
yeah i think i think there are some
funds in the world like especially the
ones that invest in like early stage
startups and things where you probably
do beat the market but normal people
don't have access to those you have to
be like ridiculously rich to be able to
invest in those sorts of funds that do
that kind of thing it's my understanding
therefore most people should just invest
in the s p 500 or a broad stock market
index fund in the uk and in the us how
would you do that
um in the uk
basically whichever country you're in
you need to get a
um
essentially a stock broker so
back in the day a stock broker was some
dude on wall street that you would ring
up and say hey
tom i want to put 20 on apple and he'd
be like all right i'm placing that order
these days stock brokers are online so
you have these online stock trading
platforms and it varies between
different countries in the uk and the us
and a bunch of countries in europe
vanguard is the most trusted it was the
original kind of index fund place so you
just open an account with vanguard
and you put some money into it like
let's say you start with ten dollars a
hundred dollars a thousand dollars
whatever and then you can allocate that
money to one of these funds and the one
that i'm fully invested in is the s p
500 which is just the 500 biggest
companies in the us i don't think too
hard beyond it about it beyond that
um so that's what i'd suggest use google
best online stock broker
heartbreaks is quite popular in the uk
that's quite easy to set up yep uh and
you can tie that in the allowance in the
uk is 20 000 pounds per year that you
can put in tax free
and the
returns are also
not taxed on that so over time that 20
will be 21 22 23.
um
so yes you can also set up a standing
order direct debit which i think is a
nice way to portion off a little bit of
money every single month i know that x
hundred pounds goes into
that and it's also that also permits you
to do what's called dollar cost
averaging which is to peace into the
market over time so the market's going
to do these little wiggles wiggly
wiggles up and down hopefully trending
upward which means that you're
continuing to earn money but by piecing
in consistently over multiple months you
don't end up ever catching too many big
or too many low points within the market
and you get out of it on the other side
all right exactly so like i have a
monthly standing order for 500 pounds
into the s p500 and
uh 2000 pounds into bitcoin and ethereum
have you seen coinbase has a smart
investing thing oh no i haven't what is
that so coinbase is a trading account
that you can use it's also a wallet for
crypto and they have a
dollar cost averaging service
that uses the movement of the price to
allocate how many how much of your funds
should go in oh so let's say that you
want to put i want to put a thousand
pounds into uh bitcoin in ethereum every
month
it will rate down or up
how much it puts in of that thousand
pounds based on the movement of the coin
during that month so if bitcoin is more
than 10 down it'll put 1 400 in but if
bitcoin is more than 10 up it'll only
put 600 in yeah so it actually sort of
smart invests based on what the recent
movement of the market has been oh
that's very sophisticated i should try
that out i'll just use the recurring buy
feature on coinbase pretty cool yeah
it's kind of like a rebalancing thing
but it happens automatically within the
app oh it's like see that and it's
pretty simple when you think about it
like has the price going up a lot okay
i'm not going to put quite so much in
has the price gone down a lot okay i'm
going to put a little bit more in less
right quite cool uh
real estate or houses yes
the thing with real estate is that um
it's
it's a pretty good way of making passive
income in that let's say you own a
property and you rent it out to people
and then they're paying you however much
a month i've recently bought a property
manchester renting it out for about a
thousand pounds a month so making about
12 000 pounds a year on on the property
the issue with real estate
um oh and and the other good thing about
real estate is that you have a physical
thing right like no one's going to argue
with depending on which country you're
no one's going to argue with the fact
that you own that house if you need to
you can live in the house so whereas if
you need to and you need to carry you
you can't live in your three percent
equity in apple like that's not really a
thing uh if you actually had frequent
equity now you probably would be able to
live in like your 0.0003
um the the the issue with real estate is
that you have to have a lot of money to
get started with it like you need enough
money for a deposit on a house in the uk
if you want to do it as an investment
you need at least 25 of the purchase
price and if a house is 300k you need
75k in cash to be able to afford that
along with all the fees on top of it and
it's also not a very liquid asset class
meaning that it's very hard to get your
money out of it because it's a ball lake
to sell a house
um so if you need the money for whatever
reason you can't just click a button
on vanguard or hogwarts lands down and
click sell you have to go through the
rigmarole of trying to sell a house
there's fees on top of it it's a
nightmare
in a way real estate is interesting
because a lot of people like probably in
our parents generation got wealthy off
of just buying a house and then not
selling it so real estate like
it makes a lot of people accidentally
good investors because the problem is
like when something is very liquid like
let's say your mom or let's say my mom
were to invest in the s p 500 she's
probably the sort of person who'd be
looking at that number every day and be
like oh my god i've just lost 100 pounds
i've just lost 200. and that would
affect her emotionally and therefore
she'd be tempted to hit the sell button
but obviously like all these investments
that we're talking about these are
long-term investments your money will
always go up in the stock market over
time
provided you don't sell at the wrong
time and the thing that real estate does
is it forces people to not sell because
it's just too much effort so
if you could like
yeah that's that's kind of why real
estate real estate is good and owning a
house is kind of nice because it just
has all these hallmarks which
accidentally make it a good investment
it's so effortful that it locks you into
holding onto the trade for so long that
it actually works yeah
that's funny yeah i think that you're
right what we've got at the beginning
here is probably
one of the easiest to put money into in
terms of stocks and shares some sort of
passive cash uh stocks and shares isa in
the uk with hargreaves lands down where
you could literally do 30 pounds a month
and then the other end of the scale
which is something which is quite cash
capital prohibitive which is buying a
house
in the uk 25 down i would budget 30
overall which would include fees stamp
duty solicitors arrangements surveys uh
and maybe a little bit of work
a little bit more but you want to paint
this wall i want to get some photos done
whatever it might be
to give my experience with this i've
just completed on my fifth house which
is all the same 25 down
on a buy to let an interest only
mortgage which means that i'm not
putting any more equity into the house
however it does mean that i get more car
it's a vehicle for generating cash for
me that's what i'm concerned about so i
don't want to pay any more into the
mortgage than i need to i don't want to
put equity into the bricks of the
building on top of the 25 that's already
there yeah what i want to do is just pay
off what i need to to the bank in order
to keep a hold of the house then the
rent that comes in from the tenants i
want to clear off as much of that as i
can over the top now
i self-managed
all of my properties up until this year
and then moved over to going managed
this would be choosing a letting agent
to be the person that the tenants ring
when the boiler breaks or when they snap
a chair or when they've locked
themselves out or when they have a
dispute about
you've charged us for cleaning when we
moved out and i don't want to
i think overall if you're considering
getting into property and if you're
looking to do a buy to let i think it's
a good idea to self-manage at least for
a year okay
reason being
this is going to be a significant
portion of your net worth that's tied up
in these houses you are going to have
conversations with the people that
manage those properties and you want to
know what they're talking about you want
to know what the dps is you want to
understand about the local licenses that
occur within wherever it is that you are
buying this is also another reason for
i think purchasing bulks of properties
within one place find a place that has a
relatively good yield and buy everything
in that yeah if you want to go and get
holiday homes and sort of play around
with things for airbnb then maybe you
could do it that way but i think that
there will be individual licensing
quirks in newcastle there's this strange
uh c4 c3 personal license hmo
system that the council's got in place
it doesn't exist anywhere else one of
the first cities that's got it in all of
the uk you need to learn that if i
decide to now go to manchester and the
council has a different rating system
i've got to learn it all over again
because i need to work out should i be
purchasing whatever whatever so you can
actually uh
reduce the
skill acquisition or the knowledge
acquisition overheads by
choosing to learn one area once and then
just digging a bunch of money into that
uh if you want to look at places to
purchase i would advise ideally near to
where you are means you can go and deal
with the leading agents one-on-one you
can have conversations with them if
there's problems with the tenants you
can go and deal with them other than
that if you are prepared if you're
somewhere that's very expensive like
london that doesn't have fantastic
yields just go on rightmove and look at
the places that have the biggest yields
i think nottingham came back as number
one this year there's places
um i want to say bournemouth was one of
them swansea was one of the newcastle
manchester
a lot of them are student towns so
that would be an overarching theme
another thing that i would say
more bedrooms is better like just get as
many bedrooms as you can in fact the way
that i try and look at the property
purchases is
how much is the cost per bedroom of this
house yep so i can get in newcastle a
three bed for around about 120
but i can get a five bed for about 150
so i try if i can to get higher bedroom
properties because they're going to
yield more and that means that you have
to wait longer until you get them but
yeah those are the two ends of the
spectrum i think we've got stocks and
shares put as little in as you need and
then we've got houses quite a lot of of
capital yes
what is your
well in fact actually capital gains is
something that we haven't spoken about
yet
which happens with the properties yeah
so if
again it kind of varies depending on
which country you're in but usually
there is some some level of tax that you
get when you dispose of an asset so if
you sell a house and the house has made
money relative to how much it was when
you bought it and it is not the house
that you live in i.e it's a rental
property then you have to pay the
government some amount of tax i think
it's like 20
uh for basic taxpayers and was it 10
percent i can't remember exactly what
the number is that's only of the
increase in the property's value right
the increase yeah of how much extra
money you made on it and in the uk you
have like a 10 000 pound a year capital
gains allowance
uh that's why if you're investing in
stocks and shares doing it through an
isa an individual savings account i
think that's what it stands for is
useful because isos are always tax free
and so for example if you put in 20 000
like right now and 30 years down the
line it had grown to i don't know 120
000 pounds
but if if it was within the context of
an isa you wouldn't pay any tax on that
120k but if it wasn't you'd end up being
taxed on the hundred thousand pounds of
gain you'd made on it and you'd be
losing 20 to 40 000 to the government in
in tax so isis are very useful for that
reason that's another thing it's a hedge
having a property is a hedge against
inflation right
uh yes um
yeah people often say that so the nice
thing about properties is that
if inflation is very high it means
actually that your mortgage is getting
cheaper
because you're still paying the same
amount of money back to the bank
theoretically unless you have a variable
rate mortgage but let's say you've got a
fixed rate mortgage which is fixed at
in america they fix them for like 30
years in the uk fix them for like up to
up to five years usually yeah
so let's say your mortgage is fixed at
like an interest rate of two percent for
five years
and then inflation goes up to ten
percent you know god forbid
you're still paying just two percent
extra um two percent uh each year and so
the value of the money
the the money that you have borrowed to
buy the house
it becomes less valuable uh and
therefore you're essentially paying off
your house by default because of
inflation also usually the price of
houses the value of the house tends to
increase greater than the rate of
inflation in any case so you will earn
money presumably on the house's value
increasing over time housing market only
goes up someone said once and
yeah that ends up with you hedging
against inflation whilst having a
capital gains vehicle that earns cash in
the moment and also potentially earns
you more cash when you come to sell at
the end yeah that's that's another thing
that's nice about real estate uh similar
to some stocks
uh you make money through the value of
the stock price increasing but you also
make money through some companies paying
dividends to their shareholders so i
don't know if you invest in coca-cola or
something you might make a few tens of
pounds each quarter when they when they
when they put our dividends similarly
with real estate you you could make more
you could make money when you sell it 10
years down the line because the pro
values increased but you're also making
money each month because people are
paying you rent so it's pretty nice but
it really is a vehicle for which the
rich get rich it's such a mucky
principle man yeah and i see this i see
this within my own experience so it took
me
from finishing uni it took me four years
to buy my first house and then it took
me two years to buy my second and then
one year to buy my third and then six
months to buy my fourth so there is just
this perfect
parabolic is that it exponential
something like that yeah just this
perfect line coming back in yeah and um
yeah you see it happen in front of your
own eyes you really do all right youtube
how do people make money on youtube oh
so many different ways uh the most
obvious one is youtube adsense or google
adsense those five second ads that play
before videos maybe like this one if
people are watching it on on youtube and
on average people will make roughly
two dollars 1.50 per thousand views so
if this video gets a thousand views
you'll be making two dollars nicely done
um but also there are people youtubers
can make money through sponsorships so
you've got a bunch of sponsorships on
your show um
and roughly you can expect to be making
very very roughly fifteen dollars per
thousand views on a sponsorship so again
let's say this let's say your videos on
average get a hundred thousand views you
can probably make fifteen hundred
dollars through
a sponsor that would be will pay fifteen
hundred dollars for you to plug their
huel or whatever skillshare audible
squarespace blah blah
to your 100 000 viewers so those are
kind of the two main ways to make money
off of youtube there's all these other
extra bits like super chat and like
subscriptions and stuff which is a very
a very small part of it um but really
the way youtubers make the big bucks
isn't through
google ads or through brand deals
particularly is usually through creating
their own products which they they can
then sell to their audience yes before
we get on to that podcasts are pretty
much the same you've got this episode is
brought to you by that happens
beforehand now we've gone from two very
passive forms of income into
podcasts on youtube which is
significantly more active yeah so this
is more for someone that actually wants
a legit side hustle
yeah i think it sort of depends how you
define passive income like
in a way the way i view youtube videos
is that a youtube video is also an asset
and an asset is something that puts
money in your pocket whereas a liability
or an investment something that puts
money in your pocket a liability
something that takes money away from
your pocket and so if i put in three
hours into making a youtube video that
youtube video is sitting on the platform
forever and it's making me money while
i'm sleeping that's pretty cool
um
in in fact
most of my youtube videos will perform
better than the house that i've just
bought as a rental property because they
make more money per month than someone
pays in rent oh i won't say most uh but
like relative to the amount of effort it
was to make the video and the amount of
money i put into the property my yield
on a youtube video or an online course
is so much higher than my yield on
buying buying a house which is kind of
weird weird when you think about it but
yeah youtube videos podcast episodes
podcast episodes are not so much because
you like get the money as a one-off as a
brand deal unless they happen to be on
youtube where you're making the ads as
well but it's kind of like any time you
make a video it's like you've just
bought a rental property and that video
is working for you and giving you rent
every single month yes digital products
you've said that this is one of the ways
that online creators that build up an
audience can monetize more effectively
yeah so um
digital products are a subset of
products generally i.e
selling selling stuff and the two
broadways you can sell sell stuff and
this is like you know it's how they
phrase it in uk law
you either sell goods or you sell
services
now let's say
i i could sell you a service quest i
could sell you the service of i don't
know personal training you know because
you obviously need to
need a personal trainer i can provide
you personal training as a service you
can pay me for my time in giving you and
giving you personal training as a
service now if it just so happened that
i built an audience based off of fit
health and fitness content then there
are some people in my audience who might
want to pay me to be their personal
trainer that's me selling a service to
someone
alternatively i could sell goods and
within goods i could sell physical goods
or digital goods physical goods would be
a youtuber saying hey buy my merch buy
my t-shirt buy my mug and they'd make 7
10 20 30 pounds on a t-shirt or a mug
and some of their audiences some of
their audience would buy the physical
product i think the most interesting
form is digital products i think it's
more interesting than the services and
more interesting than physical goods a
digital product is someone someone like
peter mckinnon a photography
videographer youtuber saying hey buy my
lightroom presets or it's someone like
august bradley saying hey buy my online
course or buy my notion template or buy
my website template or buy my icon pack
and there are people that have made
millions tens of millions hundreds of
millions off the back of selling digital
products
and the great thing about digital
products is that you generally you make
it once and then it costs you no extra
money or time to give it out to sell it
to five people as it does to sell it to
five million people whereas if i want to
sell five people a shirt i have to
manufacture produce and sell and you
know manage five shirts if i want to
sell five million shirts i need to get a
whole warehouse to get hold it's it's a
real nightmare selling five million
shirts
and it eats into your margins it's a big
house
it's not at all a nightmare to sell five
million copies of a website template
that's like free money basically
the scalability on the internet is a
site to behold
other things that people have may have
seen would be something like a workout
plan a one-off workout plan that is
different to having a course or a
membership service that gives you
workouts regularly so you can write a
pdf let's say that you're a pt you
decide to write up 30 days of emom
workouts or 30 days of
high intensity workouts whatever it
might be that can exist on the internet
let's say that someone has some sort of
speciality and they think i want to
teach people to
they're a positive psychologist and they
want to give someone a guide to the
principles of positive psychology and a
little ebook or something like that how
would you
list it and sell it in the most
frictionless way um probably a website
called gumroad that's actually i've got
the the guy who invented camera of
course book there
yeah he was supposed to be on the
podcast this wednesday but we've had to
rearrange oh nice yeah i haven't read
the book it
literally arrived earlier today as a
advanced copy so we'll we'll see how
that is uh but gumroad is great you make
an account and you can just sell stuff
and they charge like a i don't know two
percent commission but they'll host it
it'll look nice it'll be all pre-done
you don't need to learn how to code
exactly you just put a link on your
youtube description it takes three
seconds to list a product from gumroad
and then you can just literally start
making money
yeah
online courses online courses online
courses are an interesting class of
digital products because if you're a
nerd and you're teaching something to
your audience
um generally
okay so if we take a step back generally
there's like
the you can split up content into
entertainment content or educational
content and for people like you and me
who are doing educational rather than
entertainment content no offense um
our audience is primed to think of us as
teachers and therefore if we were to
make an online course teaching the same
stuff that we teach on our youtube
channels maybe in a bit more depth maybe
with a bit more structure
then the audience of our youtube channel
is primed to be also interested in oh i
wonder i i i want to hear chris teach me
about passive income i want to hear
chris teach me about his morning routine
i want to hear chris teach me about how
to launch a podcast because he's done
well with the whole podcast thing and
the nice thing about an online course
again is that
you just record it once if it's a kind
of self-paced online course you put the
videos up online on a website like podia
which is my favorite or teachable or
there's all these different platforms
where you pay a small fee like 29 a
month but they host your product they
handle the payment they handle the
checkout page they handle the forgot
password user login you don't need to
learn to code or anything you just
literally upload your videos and then
within a minute you can start selling an
online course to your audience and
online courses are how i've made the
bulk of my money over the last like 10
years
passive online courses but also this new
class which you've capitalized on which
is cohort based online courses what's
the difference there yeah so we've got
passive online courses which is the
the the traditional thing you might
expect from an online course you sign up
you pay maybe a few tens or a few
hundreds of dollars and then you've got
this library of videos that you can
watch through at your own pace basically
a passive online course is glorified
youtube videos just in a structure with
a paywall behind it this is really
convenient it's very convenient for the
creator because they just have to record
them once it's quite convenient for the
viewer because they can watch it at
their own pace
exactly it's like with netflix you can
watch a whole season in one go if you
really want to you don't have to wait
for the next episodes to come out
the issue with online courses is passive
online courses is that they have a
famously low completion rate like i've
signed up to dozens of online courses
that i've never even once opened or
watched the first two lessons and i'm
like oh can i bother to do this anymore
that's what most people are like like i
think two percent optimistically is the
completion rate of like a generic
passive online course
and so there are people who have been
like okay online courses benefit from
the scale of the internet but if you're
really thinking about
offering a transformation to your
students
they're unlikely to get it through a
passive online course unless they are
particularly self-motivated so now
there's this whole new
vibe of online courses uh that they call
cohort based courses
which is sort of actually mimicking the
way that like
real life education is done like when
you sign up to do a degree you aren't
signing up for an online course that you
can watch at your own pace although
depending on what degree you do that
ends up being ends up being the case and
you end up teaching yourself
exactly yeah in fact to be honest even
pre-pandemic most of my med school
teaching was through youtube videos
um but that aside you know you're paying
a large amount of money you're getting
this experience you're part of a cohort
you're part of community of people
you're getting these live lectures
you're getting these workshops these
tutorials these supervisions and at the
end of it you get some sort of skill
some sort of qualification some sort of
you become a doctor maybe if you're
doing if you're doing medicine a live
cohort online course is trying to do the
same thing just doing it over zoom
rather than in real life so i run one
called the part-time youtuber academy
you're thinking of maybe starting below
yeah thank you where every three months
we run a new cohort it lasts for
somewhere between four and six weeks we
change it up depending on how we're
feeling and twice a week i rock up to
zoom call i teach people for two hours
for live sessions and then we have a
bunch of interactive things we have a
bunch of like small group teaching
sessions that's a lot of work it means
we can charge more for it so we charge
at the moment between fifteen hundred
and five thousand dollars per place it's
still way cheaper than a similar course
would be in real life but it's way more
expensive than a passive online course
would be but hopefully
it's good for students who can afford it
because they recognize that it's it's
sort of like
you don't need a personal trainer to
work out but
and you and you definitely could get
hench by yourself by following an online
workout plan or just doing it yourself
but for a lot of us who don't have a lot
of time on our hands who don't rate our
own motivation or accountability very
high having a personal trainer is really
really helpful similarly you could do a
course passively online and if you've if
you're self-motivated enough to get the
value from it then that's fantastic i
think where live cohorts benefit is in
the accountability and the community
that you get around it not so much the
content which makes people do the thing
more because often the barrier between
you know if you think about say if
you're listening to this and you've been
wanting to start a youtube channel or a
podcast the reason you haven't yet is
not a lack of information the
information is like i i hold my husband
it's all freely available internet on
the internet the reason you haven't is
because you haven't got that push you
haven't got the accountability you
haven't got that community so that's
what you're paying for in a live cohort
course so i recommend you should start
one it shows i think the
importance of compliance that if you get
someone to actually comply to the things
that you do the vast majority of people
are going to see results and what you
get is
this
feeling of discomfort when you do a
cohort based course especially if you
have tasks that are supposed to be
handed in each week so with yours you
have all i want you to do by the end of
this course is recorded a youtube video
every single week and you see other
people are posting oh god god i haven't
done my youtube video yet so
yeah there's there's an interesting i'm
sure that someone's probably created a
matrix of the amount of work that it
takes for the creator
and the amount of money that you can get
back from
the customer in terms of this it is more
effortful to do a cohort based course
significantly more it's more time
consuming but also the amount that you
can charge and the results that you get
for the customer are higher if you have
a single delivery digital product that
is literally a one-and-done if you have
a passive consumption for an online
course there's usually some form of
community sometimes alongside that like
some sort of facebook group or something
or circle where you can go and do that
um
i think that
with those particular areas of skill
sets you really i'm am i right in
thinking that you probably need to aim
at building an audience organically with
something like a podcast or youtube or
instagram before you then try and launch
a course like just launching a course
off your own back posting it on your
twitter to your thousand followers and
hoping that someone buys might be a
poor way to invest your time yeah um
this
there's a bit of uh a bit of nuance here
so
i think a passive online course if you
have a small audience is not really
worth very much because if you think if
you have a thousand followers on twitter
maybe if you're really lucky ten percent
of them will buy your course
more more realistically at one percent
so let's say 10 people one percent of
your audience buys your course and let's
say you charge i don't know 100 for your
course you're making a thousand dollars
which is which is good money but it
probably took you like a large amount of
time to put this course together now
let's say you have the same thousand
followers on twitter and they're
following you because they know you
tweet about this one very specific thing
and you create a live cohort online
course on it about the thing and let's
say i don't know 0.5 so less than that
let's say 0.5 of your customers decide
to buy the thing but you're charging 2
000 for it instead
now you can have this like very very
intimate experience with these this very
small group of people that knows likes
and trusts you already they want your
expertise on the topic and they're happy
to pay you two thousand dollars for it
so in fact if you sell five of them
you've made ten thousand dollars and if
you do that a few times a year you've
made a full-time living off the back of
a thousand twitter followers provided
the value you're providing is specific
enough for people to want to pay for so
i think in the old school model of like
passive stuff passive courses it very
much is the case that you should build
the audience first and monetize the
audience second but i think you actually
can monetize an audience that's quite
quite small if you want to through the
back of a coaching program or a live
live cohort course i still wouldn't
recommend it i still think as gary
vaynerchuk would say it's better to put
your effort into growing the audience
before you try and monetize it but when
do you know when you've grown the
audience enough
uh the way i think of it is like at what
point if i monetize my audience now
would it be an interesting amount of
money that would change my life in some
capacity so if i had 100 people in my
audience and i was making ten dollars a
month it's not worth it if i'm making
100 a month it's not worth it if i'm
making a thousand dollars a month uh it
depends what stage of you yeah of life
your life you're at but when i was
younger a thousand dollars a month for
me would have been sufficiently
game changing to warrant doing the
monetization whereas a hundred dollars a
month uh it's it means i can get an
extra few takeaways it doesn't add
anything meaningful to my life so that's
how i kind of think about it um i'm sure
there are other other frameworks as well
i was talking to you earlier on about
fitness and some of the ways that people
monetize in the fitness industry they
really have turned this up to 11. the
one thing that they haven't got a hold
of yet are cohort based courses so no
one really in the fitness industry as
far as i'm aware uh apart from
fitpros teaching other fit pros to make
digital products that is one that has
because they're so far ahead of the
curve but no one's really got into
transformation cohort based courses in
the way that i think
you quite can yet they'll bundle people
together and say begin this and in six
weeks time we'll all post our progress
photos yeah but it's just not quite the
same because the consumption of the
product that you're doing is inherently
in the real world as opposed to in the
digital world yeah so going through it
together it's like oh today's workout
was hard but you weren't there i mean it
wasn't like i didn't watch you do yours
and you didn't watch me do mine but
certainly pts that are out there and
there will be a lot of people that are
pts that are listening or work in gyms
you have a captive audience they're the
people that you train week in week out
you have maybe
30 clients 40 clients perhaps that you
deal with every single month they are
people that you can monetize off the
back of if you want to write a nutrition
guide if you want to do whatever you
could even offer it to
new clients as a bonus for them coming
on you could sell it to old clients that
have lapsed i think that it's just a
nice way especially if you have
expertise in an area it's such a nice
and easy way to just add a little bit of
extra money on that being said it is
effortful you're going to have to write
it um
gumroad for digital products
teachable podia kajabi
for online courses
cohort based courses has anyone got that
platform right yet uh there's lots of
companies trying to build it there's one
called virtually that we we sort of use
another one called co-leap which is run
by some friends of mine no one's quite
got it fully right yet people are
working on it we use a combination of
virtually google sheets zapier zoom it's
a bit of a junky setup that's duct taped
everyone that i know that does cohort
based courses has this
super
village like cottage industry cable tied
together just using if this then that
framework and zapier to whole
desperately trying to hold the business
together circle vimeo that kind of stuff
yeah disgusting affiliate marketing
affiliate marketing uh the idea here is
that instead of selling your own product
you're selling someone else's product
and you're getting a percentage
commission so the biggest affiliate
program in the world is amazon
associates basically anyone can sign up
to an affiliate for amazon so that let's
say you do a video reviewing i don't
know the latest sony camera and you put
an amazon affiliate link in the video
description if someone buys the product
through your affiliate link you make
maybe somewhere between a one percent
and three percent commission which if
they're paying three thousand dollars
for a camera is actually not bad that's
it you know thirty to ninety dollars i
think if my math is right if they're
paying 4.99 for a kindle ebook you have
to sell a lot of them to make any decent
money off of that so that's how
affiliate programs work amazon gives you
very low commissions like broadly
broadly speaking but if you can partner
up with
individual brands uh i work with a
company called paperlike a keyboard
company called iq unix at that point you
can negotiate things like 10 20 30
sometimes even 50 affiliate commissions
offer the things that you sell and it
doesn't have to be just digital products
or physical products it can also be
online courses so i'm an affiliate for
like my friend pat flynn's and tiago
forte and david perell's online courses
we've got a bunch of affiliates for our
course it's generally like a win-win way
of selling someone else's product that
you believe in that your audience will
then be more likely to buy because
you've recommended it and you get a
percentage of you you get a commission
on it it's like it's like being a
salesman but in on the internet yeah
well i mean everyone believes in
something there are all things that we
rate i rate my mates barbara's shop
because that's where i go and i know
that he'll look after your hair i rate
that club night man you're going out on
a thursday you should go to this
particular place all that we're talking
about here is formalizing that agreement
and getting a bit of a kickback
i think
affiliate marketing in some circles kind
of gets a bit of a bad name because it
creates a perverse incentive for someone
to oversell you on what kind of sounds
like a personal recommendation
but that being said
well i mean that identifies why it's
such a low
amount of commission that amazon sells
you or offers you because you could sell
anything
the fact is that everybody needs
something and they're probably going to
get it on amazon and if you're the
intermediary what have you done like
what were you there for it was either
the oral b diamond white or the philips
sonicare yeah and you just happened to
direct them one way or the other you
haven't actually brought any trade here
um it's funny that you talk about if you
manage to sell someone on a expensive
product versus on a bunch of kindles
i have got affiliate links in all of the
ebooks that i've released so the life
hacks list and in the uh reading list as
well both of which have got all tracked
amazon links which i just thought would
be interesting and it's passive income
so why not and i looked
it took a long time to write the 100
books reading list and the entire amount
of all of that income has topped up to
about 12 pounds i think because it's
you're talking about three pounds kindle
some of them are free yeah some people
have got audible subscriptions so
they're just using it on their audible
which means that i don't get anything
and then one guy because you can
actually track um what product brought
people to amazon on your amazon
affiliates back end
what brought people to amazon and then
what did they what did they buy
downstream from that yeah and this one
guy bought a ps5 so somebody dude went
on to buy the almanac of novalravacam
and then bought a ps5 i was like yes
like 10 pounds 50. and that was that was
like the big earner for the for the year
yeah so funny man but um yeah are there
any other affiliate marketing
easy access affiliate marketing
uh platforms or
sections that you think people should
take advantage of yeah i think if you
have an audience and you have a product
or an online thing that you like uh the
first thing i would do is
google have they got an affiliate
program so like the other day i was
thinking i started watching some master
classes malcolm gladwell's writing
masterclass oh i wonder if masterclass 7
affiliate program so i typed in
masterclass affiliate program and then i
found that they've got some
uh
it seemed like it was active some of the
time and not active some of the time
the other option is if they don't have
an affiliate program you can easily sign
up to is you can't just email them and
say hey have you got an affiliate
program yeah and i've had success in
companies setting up an affiliate
program just for me for you because i
emailed them because but like where i
could say look i really like this
keyboard i'm pretty sure i can drive a
lot of traffic to your keyboard can you
please make an affiliate program here's
what i'd recommend and they're like
after a few months yeah right and then
it works so you can do surprising things
like that that i wouldn't have thought
about otherwise yeah it's um
it is funny it is funny how you're able
to make money online in that way by
directing people around the internet i
suppose that
what a lot of these are coming back to
is that you need to have a trusted
network of people who are coming to you
who believe what you say you'll have
faith in your word
have you got any suggestions for how
people creators online
should
improve their trust with their audience
yeah
yeah that's the tricky thing because you
know what they say is it's like you know
it takes a lifetime to build up and like
an instant to lose
and i've certainly done a few times
where we've put out a video where uh
it's kind of because we just had a
sponsored deadline coming up and i
didn't really stand by the value of the
video but we put it out anyway and a
that always feels really bad for me but
also people can tell like oh this is
this was a throwaway video this wasn't
the usual quality
and really i think trust is built up by
showing up regularly and by delivering
delivering value
um the way gary vaynerchuk puts it is
like any time you give someone something
for free like valuable content for free
you're adding to the goodwill bank bank
balance with that person and anytime you
try and sell them something generally
you're you're withdrawing from that bank
of goodwill and so
he advocates a strategy of he calls it
jab jab jab right hook where a jab is
giving someone really valuable content
for free and a right hook is asking them
to buy something from you and he
famously says that if he like he's
written a book called jab jab jab right
hook but he says that if he could he
would have named it jab jab jab jab
like 20 times before the right hook
because that is the ratio of how much
you should be helping people out with
free valuable content
compared to asking them for the sale
um but he wasn't allowed to name it
because the publisher you end up with
latent leverage which is what jack
butcher calls it the fact that you have
all of this goodwill that's built up and
built up and built up and then you
finally ask people for something yeah so
when the life hacks list released last
year
my convertkit got shut down because on
the first day that we launched it we did
5000 email addresses and they presumed
that i'd bugged something or i'd broken
something and i had to actually get in
touch with the ceo on twitter to say
dude i'm driving a lot of people to this
landing page can you please get them to
reactivate it and he gave me a call
actually he was really really kind and
said i'm really sorry congratulations on
the launch it's obviously gone well um
but that
what that taught me was that i'd left it
too long before i'd started capturing
email addresses from my audience because
if i had so much latent leverage sat
there three years nearly 200 episodes of
a podcast yeah more um and i'd only just
started asking them for even that was
free even that was me still adding value
i just wanted an email address in return
that kind of made me think okay
i probably could have done this a little
bit sooner and that's an interesting
thing to consider that you can wait too
long to do this too
and
yeah jumping
finding the right balance i think when
you've built up sufficient goodwill a
good place to start must be to build an
email list because that is
a halfway house exactly yeah so
the way a lot of online marketing
funnels work it's like you have people
coming in through your website or
through your youtube channel or
instagram or tech talk or whatever and
you want to get them onto an email list
because you don't really own that
audience in inverted commas you don't
really own that audience when it's on
someone else's platform youtube owns the
audience or tiktok owns the audience but
you do really own that audience when you
have an email list like when you have
someone's email address you're they're
giving you permission to show up in
their inbox assuming you don't get spam
filtered by gmail or whatever um and so
really the first step and once
you're almost from day one it's sensible
to start building an email list and it's
very easy thing to do you've got your
email newsletter which is fantastic and
it's just you know you're you're you're
delivering value week after week um
where people have signed up to hear from
you and therefore maybe once a year when
you launch a product you can email that
list being like hey guys i'm launching
this thing do you want to buy it here's
a link and those people are primed to
buy from you because that you've been
showing up in their inbox building up
your trust with them week after week for
for a long period of time yeah yeah
that's a good one
uh
what would you use what would you advise
someone to use let's say that they think
i i have a little bit of an audience i
want to start building an email list
what's the easiest most frictionless way
to do that
a few different platforms these days so
sub stack and review are free review is
actually built into twitter so i i
actually had my email list on review for
like three years before i moved it to
convertkit um so review is what i'd
recommend rev ue um once you're ready to
take email marketing a bit more
seriously uh you can switch to something
like convertkit
uh which is very good but it is quite
expensive uh so after your first
thousand subscribers which are free so
i'd start with review or sub stack yeah
the thing i like about review is it's
got on your twitter account especially
if you're big on twitter it's got a
subscribe right there at the top of your
twitter profile um what i would say i
hope review i'm watching this what i've
done is i've just set up my review yep
at the top and i just pull the emails
across every day into convertkit or
every once once a week so you can take
advantage of the frictionless sign up
yes on twitter but then pull them across
into your main convertkit yeah that's
what we do we we use a zap for that as
well
oh
you're gonna have to send me that yeah
so you can automate it yeah anytime
someone signs up to review you you're
going to make a zap in three seconds
that sends ads them as a converted
subscriber that's sick okay i didn't
know about that uh membership membership
sites membership sites so the idea here
is that um you
get some of your audience you charge
them a monthly membership fee and bring
them into some sort of premium
offering patreon is one example of a
membership site uh where the vibe of
patreon is hey support my work for five
dollars a month and in return you'll get
early access to my videos or you'll get
to a live q a with me every month um
gary vaynerchuk often says that if
someone is your super fan the thing
they'll pay for is more access to you so
more of your content more if you're
behind the scenes that kind of stuff
that's one way of doing a membership
thing and the nice thing about
memberships is that people will pay you
monthly so you've got recurring income
the annoying thing about memberships is
that you do then have to be showing up
every single month to provide value
otherwise it's a bit unfair and so
actually i tried to do a membership
thing with my youtuber academy we called
it the inner circle which was afterwards
for alumni charging 50 to 100 a month uh
and we had like weekly events going on
and we had that we we had a lot of
activities but even with weekly events
and sometimes twice weekly events i
still felt we weren't providing enough
value
compared to the ridiculous amount of
value we provide in the course and so we
ended up canceling it after six months
and just refunding everyone any money
they'd ever paid which was like 150 000
worth of refunds that we did but it was
for the sake of that trust because i was
like no there's no way
it wasn't fair for us to like i wouldn't
i i didn't feel good about charging
people for that value that we were
offering so patreon is one way to do a
membership you can build your own
membership site using something like
ghost which is what i use for my
personal website which is very good um
there's a few other options like paid
newsletters on substance
you can get people in through youtube
page subscriptions which is built into
youtube uh where you can get them into a
discord community there's all sorts of
different ways of doing membership
content but the idea is that
some of your some of your audience will
be happy to pay a certain amount of
money each month but if you if you're
if you want to be in kind of integrity
about it you want to give them decent
amounts of value every month
you can't you can't just put people into
a group and hope for the best so locals
which is the platform that i've just
started using one of the reasons i
really like that over patreon and i've
vacillated for ages and ages thinking do
i want to use patreon do i want to go
with locals now i ended up choosing
locals mostly because it permits
inter-community bonding so community
members can post in there they can have
discussions between themselves every day
an episode goes up there's a thread
talking about it yeah whereas patreon
because it's established and there's an
expected uh modus operandi on there it's
here is a new piece of content for you
enjoy here is a new piece of content for
you watch here is a whatever like a
little update or something it doesn't
feel as organic and natural yeah so
locals for me felt like a really really
good platform choice there's another
platform that's owned by
patreon
and it's i think it's called member full
oh yes the pay walls yeah paywalls word
wordpress sites so let's say that you've
got a wordpress site that you want to
have some work behind a paywall on it
and they can integrate that i think
there's a way that they can actually
integrate those member lists with some
other some other fancy things through
zapier or through ifttt and um
yeah that would be interesting why
didn't you go for patreon plus discord
i wanted everything to be in one
site i also think that discord itself as
a platform is a very particular portion
of the internet
that understands what discord is knows
how to use it and although most people
would be adaptable
i felt like locals was just such a
frictionless it's built for conversions
it's built for creators you click on the
link there is a big button that says
join yup email password sign up click
the confirmation and you're in a nice
photo of you as well yeah it's beautiful
beautiful photo the popeye popeye arms
someone accused me of looking like who
was that guy from fast and furious that
died
oh karma's name paul walker yeah a cross
between paul walker and popeye which i
took as a that's a compliment it took as
a compliment but it might not have been
uh automating a business what's that
mean
automating business um a good reading on
this is tim ferriss's four hour work
week which uh kind of i guess put this
this idea on the map
but basically if you have a business
let's say i don't know your
let's say you're selling a physical
product let's say i'm selling a t-shirt
that actually is more like a traditional
business than an online business like
even if i take orders online i still
have to fulfill the orders i have to
figure out a way of like you know
getting the customer size getting a
payment from the customer um
printing the t-shirt they want printed
or getting it shipped from my warehouse
to their address tracking the phone that
is shipped to their address making sure
they're happy with it making some having
someone monitor the support in books
because if they email me for whatever
reason i need to be able to reply to
them having someone deal with refunds if
for whatever reason their t-shirt didn't
arrive there's a lot of stuff associated
with that now if you run if you're
trying to do this all yourself it ends
up taking a large amount of time and you
realize hang on i if i want to scale
this business i don't have enough hours
in the day to be able to manually
package up and ship out all my orders
and therefore you can start adding ways
you can delegate and automate aspects of
your business
so bits that you can delegate is you
could theoretically hire someone to
manage your support inbox or you could
hire someone to ship the orders from the
warehouse
a way you can automate it is you can
create you can use something like zapier
to say that okay whenever a customer
places an order i wanted to
automatically send an email to my
warehouse person to say hey someone has
placed an order that means i don't have
to send him a whatsapp message anymore
when a customer emails our support inbox
i want it to automatically send a ping
to our slack channel which my support
person is handling so they can get
they can they can reply to the message
immediately if someone sends us an email
with a word refund in it i wanted to
automatically just refund them on stripe
or paypal without even me having to
think about it because i don't really
care there's all these different things
you can do to automate and delegate
aspects of your business which is
ultimately what you need to do to scale
because your own time as a business
owner is limited to 24 hours in a day
and as a business owner you can probably
do more valuable things than reply to
refund requests or things like that so
this is about freeing up time around the
business as opposed to particularly
creating separate streams of income
yes generally um you probably could
create separate streams of income if you
had a business with some automated
elements
uh
that would be a bit a bit more unusual
generally automation and delegation is
to free up your own time and then that
makes your business a bit more passive
so a lot of passive income sources start
out as being very active and then you
passivify them through automation and
delegation yeah building an app or a
website
okay building an app is really hard um
if it's a mobile tried uh yes have you
no okay yeah it sounds like a nightmare
yeah building a website is easier uh
with tools for websites and stuff html
css fairly easy to learn you can learn
those in about a week if you find a
youtube youtube video and do if you end
up with it a little bit there's all this
stuff around like progressive web
applications there's ways of building
ios and android apps through building a
website and porting it onto android and
ios it all gets very complicated um i
think
the thing is
if you can build a website there's a
there's a branch of
software called software as a service
sas saas
that is where some so something like
patreon is actually software as a
service um
patreon has built the software that
allows memberships to work and therefore
when creators sign up to patreon they're
paying a subscription or paying a
commission to patreon something like
paypal is weirdly software as a service
it is a piece of software that allows
people to accept payments
um when i was in med school my brother
and i built something called bmat and
ucat ninja which was software as a
service it was a website that allowed
people to subscribe for 30 pounds of pop
to do questions to prepare for their
medical school entrance exams
these are all the things these are all
things that you can do
if you want to build a website from
scratch it's it's quite hard to do that
um
but i mean most like uber is
an app which someone built twitter
facebook all these like incredibly high
valuation ridiculously successful apps
or ultimately someone starting off mark
zuckerberg building facebook in his dorm
room or building hot or not in his dorm
room
it's an interesting skill to have and i
still recommend to this day if anyone
wants to get rich on the internet
learning to code is a really really
useful skill to have um but it's not
easy is there anything you've missed off
because you did this video a while ago
about different passive income streams
and we've gone through some of them
today looking back is there anything
that you've developed since then that
you wish that you put in
i think one interesting passive income
stream that we haven't really talked
about is coaching and we mentioned it a
little bit with the personal trainer
stuff but if you can become a coach for
someone i know a lot of personal
trainers do online coaching whereby they
don't even need to be on a zoom call
with someone they can just sort of
create like a workout plan and for
example athleanx probably has an online
coaching program he's probably not the
one actually
tracking people's macros and stuff
there's probably some level of
automation and delegation there so i
think that coaching is an interesting
income stream because you don't need
that many coaching clients to make a
decent amount of money if you have a
small audience you can monetize them
pretty effectively through coaching
provided you're teaching something
useful you're providing value to your
audience
um so that's an income stream that
people can double with if they want
chris sparks has an interesting article
about that talking so just search chris
sparks and consultancy i think he called
it and it was just discussing how
people don't really see
service-based businesses on the internet
the same as many others he was
identifying the fact that a lot of
weight lies on your shoulders if you
want to be whether that be an online
coach or a mindset coach or someone
that's helping someone with team work or
working through relationships or dating
advice whatever it might be it is great
but the scalability of that is
inherently downturned because you for
the most part are the person you're the
product exactly yeah one half an hour of
your time equals one half an hour of
your customers time which means that if
you only want to work
eight hours a day you can only have 16
customers a day as opposed to the
scalability that you get from products
and online exactly yeah coaching is a
very it's not passive unless you find a
way to automate and delegate it which
kind of takes away from the charm of it
being you as their personal coach yeah
yeah so to recap we've got
differing amounts of input in terms of
both time and capital that we need to
use yep looking to try and have a spread
of a a variety of income streams as
possible is good because it hedges you
against different markets either moving
up or moving down it also means that you
can monetize more effectively across
different streams and building an
audience going audience first adding
value first thin end of the wedge over
delivering on the freemium side that is
something that's going to help anything
else what else has been missed off from
the from the recipe for success um
i find like
when i'm thinking about passive income
uh i kind of often think of the three
c's which is i think something that
naval talks about uh capital code and
content
and you can make money through capital
by investing in stocks investing in real
estate you can make money through code
by building an app building a website
you can make money through content by
creating a youtube channel podcast
twitter instagram tick tock writing a
blog writing a book all that kind of
stuff
and then the then you've got the actual
traditional businesses like selling a
thing or selling a service and then
applying the delegation and automation
processes to that but capital code and
content
have an unfair advantage in that they
benefit from the scale from
uh pre-existing passiveness i.e capital
and the internet i.e code and content
whereas a traditional business you have
to do a bit more extra work to make that
into a passive income source by
delegating and automating and even then
traditional businesses are so much lower
margin like you know if you're selling a
physical product it's just going to be
lower margin than if you're selling a
piece of code or a piece of content so
that's sort of how i think about it in
my head i think might be useful for
people to have that uh framework i like
it ali abdel ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with what
you do give us chill your online wares
show my online wares yeah just check out
my youtube channel search alibaba on
youtube it'll probably be linked in the
video description it's all good thanks
thanks for having me on what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace